Add a pop of culture to every room in your house with SiriusXM. Stream over 425 channels of ad-free music, plus exclusive talk, world-class news, live play-by-play sports, comedy, and popular podcasts with the SXM app. Subscribe to the streaming platinum plan and get your first three months for free. Visit SiriusXM.ca for details.
通过 SiriusXM 为您家中的每个房间增添一抹文化气息。使用 SXM 应用程序，您可以流媒体播放超过 425 个无广告音乐频道，以及独家访谈、世界级新闻、现场体育赛事直播、喜剧和热门播客。订阅流媒体白金计划，即可免费获得前三个月的使用权。详情请访问 SiriusXM.ca。
SiriusXM, everything you want to hear lives here. MUSIC Our episodes deal with SiriusXM and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website.
SiriusXM，您想听的一切都在这里。音乐 本期节目涉及 SiriusXM 以及一些令人不安的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上的本期节目说明。
MUSIC The Marine Corps is the smallest conventional military force in the United States. As of 2022, it has approximately 177,000 active duty members and about 32,500 personnel in reserve. The Marine's motto, Semper Fidelis, is a nod to the tight-knit culture the Corps is known for. Meaning, always faithful,
音乐 海军陆战队是美国规模最小的常规军事力量。截至 2022 年，它拥有约 177,000 名现役军人和约 32,500 名预备役人员。海军陆战队的座右铭“Semper Fidelis”是对该军种以紧密团结而闻名的文化的致敬。意思是“永远忠诚”，
the Latin phrase refers to the loyalty Marines have to their country, to their work, and to each other. In 2017, New York Times journalist Janet Reitman described them as having a... All-enlisted female recruits and male recruits who reside east of the Mississippi River undergo their training at the Paris Island Recruit Depot. Located on Port Royal Island in South Carolina,
这个拉丁短语指的是海军陆战队员对国家、对工作以及对彼此的忠诚。2017 年，《纽约时报》记者珍妮特·雷特曼（Janet Reitman）形容他们拥有……所有女性新兵以及居住在密西西比河以东的男性新兵都在帕里斯岛新兵训练营接受训练。该训练营位于南卡罗来纳州的皇家港岛，
this military installation is where roughly 17,000 Marines are trained each year. During the 13-week long training program, recruits are cut off from the outside world and undergo a physically and mentally gruelling regimen. There are four battalions at Paris Island, which recruits are assigned to according to their platoon and company.
这个军事设施每年大约训练 17,000 名海军陆战队员。在为期 13 周的训练计划中，新兵与外界隔绝，并接受身体和精神上极其严苛的训练。帕里斯岛有四个营，新兵根据其排和连被分配到这些营中。
The third recruit training battalion has a particularly imposing history. It's been described as attracting drill instructors with Type A personalities who aim to build the most disciplined Marines. The third battalion's reputation is so notorious that it has been nicknamed the Thumping Third. ...
第三新兵训练营有着一段特别令人敬畏的历史。据称，它吸引了那些具有 A 型人格的教官，他们的目标是打造纪律最严明的海军陆战队员。第三营的名声非常响亮，以至于被戏称为“重击第三营”（Thumping Third）。……
19-year-old Jake Weaver was following in a family tradition when he enlisted in the Marines. His grandfather had served in the Korean War in the early 1950s. In early 2015, Jake and his fellow recruits boarded the bus that would take them to Paris Island for their training. As soon as they arrived at their destination,
19 岁的杰克·韦弗（Jake Weaver）在加入海军陆战队时，是在追随家族传统。他的祖父曾在 20 世纪 50 年代初参加过朝鲜战争。2015 年初，杰克和他的战友们登上了前往帕里斯岛接受训练的巴士。当他们到达目的地时，
they were met by a drill instructor who barked in order at them. Get on the yellow footprints. A long line of footprints had been painted along the asphalt nearby, marking a pathway to the entrance building. Following the instructor's orders, the recruits made their way towards the building
一位教官对他们大声下达了命令。站到黄色脚印上。附近沥青路面上画着一长串脚印，标记着通往入口大楼的路径。按照教官的命令，新兵们向大楼走去，
to begin their training. Scenes inside the building were chaotic. Drill instructors bellowed at the recruits from all across the room as they filled out their intake forms and phoned their families. Recruits were permitted one call home, no longer than four seconds, and reciting a strict script.
开始他们的训练。大楼内的场景一片混乱。当新兵们填写报到表格并给家人打电话时，教官们在房间各处对他们咆哮。新兵被允许给家里打一个电话，时间不超过四秒，并且必须背诵严格的脚本。
After identifying themselves, they were to say, I have arrived safely at Paris Island. Please do not send any food or bulky items to me in the mail. I will contact you in seven to nine days by letter with my new address. Thank you for your support. Goodbye for now.
在表明身份后，他们必须说：“我已经安全抵达帕里斯岛。请不要通过邮件给我寄送任何食物或大件物品。我将在七到九天内写信给您，告知我的新地址。感谢您的支持。暂时再见。”
Over the next few days, they were given uniforms, their heads were shaved, physical fitness tests were taken, and then the real training could begin. Jake Weaver was assigned to Platoon 3054 in Lima Company, which was assigned to the Third Battalion. When he and his fellow platoon mates met their drill instructors,
在接下来的几天里，他们领到了制服，剃了光头，进行了体能测试，然后真正的训练就开始了。杰克·韦弗被分配到第三营利马连（Lima Company）的 3054 排。当他和他的排友们见到他们的教官时，
the young recruits were asked a question. You want to be trained like Marines, right? Not like crappy individual Marines. It would soon become clear what the DI's meant by this. While some drill instructors were older, others were close in age to the recruits themselves. The majority of them haven't served in combat, but instead work for the Marines
这些年轻的新兵被问了一个问题。“你们想接受像海军陆战队员一样的训练，对吧？而不是像蹩脚的个人那样。”教官们这话的意思很快就变得清晰起来。虽然有些教官年纪较大，但另一些人与新兵的年龄相仿。他们中的大多数人没有参加过战斗，而是作为空中交通管制员、机械师或技术员等角色为海军陆战队工作。
as air traffic controllers, mechanics, or technicians, amongst other roles. In order to become a drill instructor, also known as a DI, a Marine has to complete one term of enlistment and pass a psychological exam to make sure they're not suffering from PTSD. If given the all-clear,
为了成为一名教官（也称为 DI），海军陆战队员必须完成一个服役期，并通过心理测试以确保他们没有患上创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。如果获得批准，
they attend an 11-week program where they learn how to teach recruits. In Jake Weaver's experience at Parris Island, there were essentially two training programs that ran parallel to one another. By day, recruits attended classes and completed tactical missions. They completed gruelling physical exercises
他们将参加一个为期 11 周的课程，学习如何教导新兵。在杰克·韦弗在帕里斯岛的经历中，本质上有两个平行进行的训练项目。白天，新兵们上课并完成战术任务。他们完成了严酷的体能训练，
and other tasks that seemed pointless, like dangling rifles from their pinky fingers or sitting still for hours at a time. By night, an unofficial kind of training took place. Sometimes recruits weren't permitted to sleep. Drill instructors would pour detergent, shaving cream, and other toiletries on the barracks' floors and order recruits to run across it
以及其他看起来毫无意义的任务，比如用小指悬挂步枪或连续坐着不动几个小时。到了晚上，一种非官方的训练就开始了。有时新兵不被允许睡觉。教官会把洗涤剂、剃须膏和其他洗漱用品倒在营房地板上，并命令新兵在上面奔跑，
while also scrubbing the floor with brushes. Jake would later tell journalists to Janet Reitman that the drill instructors referred disparagingly to what they called the new core. They felt that the Marines had become too easy with the training being done by the book and no real struggle for the recruits. In Jake's experience,
同时用刷子擦洗地板。杰克后来告诉记者珍妮特·雷特曼，教官们贬义地称之为“新核心”（new core）。他们认为海军陆战队变得太轻松了，训练是按部就班进行的，新兵们没有真正的挣扎。在杰克的经历中，
the DI's saw it as their role to make Marines of them through hazing, a process of degrading and abusing recruits as a form of initiation. There was a tacit understanding that what happened in the barracks stayed in the barracks. As for Jake's own senior drill instructor, he was an erratic man who could be encouraging one minute
教官们认为他们的角色是通过“欺凌”（hazing）来塑造海军陆战队员，这是一种作为入伍仪式而贬低和虐待新兵的过程。人们有一种默契，即发生在营房里的事就留在营房里。至于杰克自己的高级教官，他是一个反复无常的人，可能前一分钟还在鼓励人，
and aggressive the next. Jake found the speed at which he lost his temper alarming. Under no circumstances were drill instructors permitted to touch recruits, yet this rule was often ignored. If a recruit was seen to be smiling or laughing, a DI might hit or choke them. The overexertion from the late night tasks
后一分钟就变得咄咄逼人。杰克发现他发脾气的速度令人震惊。在任何情况下，教官都不被允许触碰新兵，但这条规则经常被忽视。如果看到有新兵在微笑或大笑，教官可能会打他们或掐他们的脖子。深夜任务带来的过度劳累，
they were forced to perform led to some recruits passing out or suffering a breakdown of skeletal muscle tissue. But none of them complained. During the first week of training, Jake Weaver's platoon listened to a talk by one of their drill instructors that focused on the fraternal connection between Marines.
迫使他们执行的任务导致一些新兵昏倒或患上骨骼肌组织崩溃。但他们中没有人抱怨。在训练的第一周，杰克·韦弗的排听了一位教官的演讲，重点是海军陆战队员之间的兄弟情谊。
All of them were brothers, the instructor said, regardless of their faith, ethnicity, or race. Then he asked each recruit what their religion was. One of Jake's platoon mates was a young man from Brooklyn, New York, named Amir Bormash. When he was asked which faith he followed, Amir replied, Islam, sir. The majority of the recruits were white men
教官说，他们所有人都是兄弟，无论他们的信仰、种族或民族如何。然后他问每个新兵他们的宗教信仰是什么。杰克的一位排友是来自纽约布鲁克林的年轻人，名叫阿米尔·博马什（Amir Bormash）。当被问及他信奉什么信仰时，阿米尔回答说：“长官，伊斯兰教。”大多数新兵是白人男性，
from Christian backgrounds. Many of them had never met a Muslim before, prompting the drill instructor to reassure everyone that there was nothing wrong with Amir's faith. But from that day on, Amir seemed to be singled out for harsher treatment than the rest. Intelligent and hardworking, he always performed well on every test.
来自基督教背景。他们中的许多人以前从未见过穆斯林，这促使教官向大家保证，阿米尔的信仰没有任何问题。但从那天起，阿米尔似乎被单独挑出来接受比其他人更严厉的对待。他聪明且勤奋，在每次测试中都表现出色。
Yet the drill instructors made him undertake particularly grueling training sessions. On at least two occasions, Amir had to go to the medical unit after these incidents. One of the drill instructors from another platoon seemed to go out of his way to hassle Amir. He repeatedly called him a terrorist and asked him, where are the WMDs?
然而，教官们让他进行特别艰苦的训练。至少有两次，阿米尔在这些事件后不得不去医疗单位。来自另一个排的一名教官似乎特意去骚扰阿米尔。他反复称他为恐怖分子，并问他：“大规模杀伤性武器在哪里？”
Were you part of 9-11? These questions were a reference to the September 11, 2001 terrorist attacks on the United States by militant Islamic group Al-Qaeda. Following the attacks, the US had gone to war against Iraq under the guise of looking for weapons of mass destruction. Despite the ongoing harassment, Amir stuck with his training,
“你是 9-11 事件的参与者吗？”这些问题是指 2001 年 9 月 11 日激进伊斯兰组织“基地”组织对美国发动的恐怖袭击。袭击发生后，美国以寻找大规模杀伤性武器为借口对伊拉克发动了战争。尽管持续受到骚扰，阿米尔还是坚持完成了训练，
and in early July of 2015, he and the other recruits completed their final test and officially became Marines. Late at night on July 14, 2015, the recruits in platoon 3054 were sleeping when the silence was suddenly broken by several men entering the squad bay. It was a number of the drill instructors,
2015 年 7 月初，他和新兵们完成了最终测试，正式成为海军陆战队员。2015 年 7 月 14 日深夜，3054 排的新兵们正在睡觉，突然几个人进入了宿舍，打破了寂静。那是几名教官，
including the one who'd become fixated with Amir Bormash. He was Gunnery Sergeant Joseph Felix. Sergeant Felix and his friends appeared to have been drinking. Making his way through the squad bay, Felix asked, where's the terrorist? As he drew closer to Amir's bunk, he asked, you a terrorist? No, sir, Amir replied.
包括那个一直盯着阿米尔·博马什的教官。他是炮兵军士约瑟夫·费利克斯（Joseph Felix）。费利克斯军士和他的朋友们似乎喝了酒。费利克斯在宿舍里走来走去，问道：“恐怖分子在哪里？”当他靠近阿米尔的床铺时，他问道：“你是恐怖分子吗？”“不，长官，”阿米尔回答。
You a Muslim? said Felix. Yes, sir, answered Amir. Felix ordered him down, then he and another day I marched Amir towards the bathroom. Turning on the showers, they had Amir lie down on the tiles and do push-ups and other exercises. Amir obediently did as he was told,
“你是穆斯林吗？”费利克斯说。“是的，长官，”阿米尔回答。费利克斯命令他下来，然后他和另一名教官把阿米尔带向浴室。打开淋浴喷头，他们让阿米尔躺在瓷砖上做俯卧撑和其他练习。阿米尔顺从地照做了，
getting soaked as water from the shower heads poured down on him. This sort of activity was known as incentive training, on the spot physical training intended as a form of punishment. Eventually, the DIs told him to stop and took him to the laundry room. Get in the dryer, Felix ordered.
淋浴喷头流下的水把他淋得湿透。这种活动被称为“激励训练”，即作为一种惩罚形式的现场体能训练。最终，教官们告诉他停下来，并把他带到了洗衣房。“进烘干机里去，”费利克斯命令道。
He was referring to an industrial-sized clothes dryer big enough to fit a grown man. Amir, who was six feet tall, climbed inside. I'm going to find out who you really are, said Felix, before closing the dryer door. Who are you working for? he asked. Nobody, sir, was Amir's reply. Displeased with this answer, Felix turned the dryer on.
他指的是一台大到足以容纳一个成年男性的工业级干衣机。身高六英尺的阿米尔爬了进去。“我要查出你到底是谁，”费利克斯在关上烘干机门之前说道。“你为谁工作？”他问。“没人，长官，”阿米尔回答。对这个答案不满意，费利克斯打开了烘干机。
Amir's body tumbled inside as its drum began to turn. Back in the squad bay, the other recruits could hear the bang of Amir crashing against the bottom of the machine's interior. After about 30 seconds, Felix stopped the dryer and opened the door. What's your religion? he asked. Islam, sir, said Amir.
随着滚筒开始转动，阿米尔的身体在里面翻滚。在宿舍里，其他新兵可以听到阿米尔撞击机器内部底部的砰砰声。大约 30 秒后，费利克斯停下烘干机并打开了门。“你的宗教信仰是什么？”他问。“长官，伊斯兰教，”阿米尔说。
Felix closed the door and turned the dryer on again. You're going to kill us the first chance you get, aren't you, terrorist? What are your plans? The inside of the dryer was starting to heat up, burning Amir's shoulder and neck. He began to cry. Once again, Felix stopped the dryer
费利克斯关上门，再次打开了烘干机。“你一有机会就会杀了我们，对吧，恐怖分子？你有什么计划？”烘干机内部开始升温，灼伤了阿米尔的肩膀和脖子。他开始哭泣。费利克斯再次停下烘干机，
and demanded to know if Amir was still Muslim. When he said he was, the dryer was switched on again. Eventually, after the dryer had been turned on and off three times, Amir gave in and told them what they wanted to hear. He was no longer a Muslim. After about 30 minutes, Amir was taken back to his bunk, still damp and visibly upset.
并要求知道阿米尔是否仍然是穆斯林。当他说他是时，烘干机再次被打开。最终，在烘干机被开关三次后，阿米尔屈服了，告诉了他们想听的话。他不再是穆斯林了。大约 30 分钟后，阿米尔被带回了他的床铺，仍然湿漉漉的，明显心烦意乱。
Felix and his accomplice left, and another DI went up to Amir. It's pretty effed up what they did to you back there. You're not going to tell a senior drill instructor about this, though, right? No, sir, said Amir. The following night, Sergeant Joseph Felix returned to Platoon 3054 Squad Bay. He made Amir hand over his martial arts belt
费利克斯和他的同伙离开了，另一名教官走到阿米尔身边。“他们刚才对你做的事真是太糟糕了。不过，你不会告诉高级教官这件事的，对吧？”“不，长官，”阿米尔说。第二天晚上，约瑟夫·费利克斯军士回到了 3054 排的宿舍。他让阿米尔交出他的武术腰带，
and tied it around Amir's neck. He also tied Amir's shoelaces together and looped the belt through them, forcing Amir to bend double. Leading Amir around the bay as though he were a dog on a leash, Felix asked him, Are you a terrorist? Are you a spy?
并把它系在阿米尔的脖子上。他还把阿米尔的鞋带系在一起，并将腰带穿过鞋带，迫使阿米尔弯下腰。费利克斯像牵狗一样牵着阿米尔在宿舍里走，问他：“你是恐怖分子吗？你是间谍吗？”
No, sir, cried Amir, who was in pain from the restraint. Y'all la la Huwakba, Felix demanded. Amir did as he was told. Then Felix used a flagpole to push down on Amir's toes, crushing them, before taking a different approach. Felix handed Amir a scrubbing brush and told him to behead a fellow recruit with it. Show us you're a terrorist.
“不，长官，”阿米尔哭喊道，他因束缚而感到疼痛。“大喊‘真主至大’（Allahu Akbar），”费利克斯要求道。阿米尔照做了。然后费利克斯用旗杆压住阿米尔的脚趾，压碎了它们，然后采取了不同的方法。费利克斯递给阿米尔一把刷子，告诉他用它斩首一名战友。“向我们展示你是恐怖分子。”
Amir hit the recruits' neck several times with the brush while crying out a la Huwakba, an Arabic phrase that translates to, God is the greatest. This seemed to make Felix happy. Amir's anxiety only increased in the days that followed. He also struggled with a loss of motivation. At night, he was plagued by nightmares
阿米尔用刷子多次击打战友的脖子，同时哭喊着“真主至大”，这是一句阿拉伯语短语，翻译过来是“上帝是最伟大的”。这似乎让费利克斯很高兴。在接下来的几天里，阿米尔的焦虑感只增不减。他还努力克服动力不足的问题。晚上，他被噩梦困扰，
that featured Felix killing his family. Amir wasn't the only recruit who was troubled. Jake Weaver struggled with some of the things he'd seen during training, and although he hadn't been targeted in the same way Amir had, he found himself grappling with mistreatment as well. On one occasion, a drill instructor pushed Jake's head against the wall.
梦中费利克斯杀害了他的家人。阿米尔并不是唯一一个感到困扰的新兵。杰克·韦弗在训练中看到的一些事情让他感到挣扎，尽管他没有像阿米尔那样成为目标，但他发现自己也在与虐待作斗争。有一次，一名教官把杰克的头推向墙壁。
Another DI had mocked him for being religious. Jake had high expectations of the Marines but was growing increasingly disillusioned about serving. His mental health began to suffer and he wound up being hospitalized due to having suicidal thoughts. He decided to leave the Marines. To Jake's dismay, he found out he would be receiving
另一名教官嘲笑他有宗教信仰。杰克对海军陆战队寄予厚望，但对服役越来越感到幻灭。他的心理健康开始恶化，最终因有自杀念头而住院。他决定离开海军陆战队。令杰克沮丧的是，他发现自己将收到
an other than honorable discharge. A few months earlier in May of 2015, an email had been sent to the Parris Island Recruit Depot. There was no name attached to it, with the author instead signing off as a retired Marine and a concerned parent. It read in part, I apologize for writing an anonymous email
一份“非荣誉退伍”（other than honorable discharge）。几个月前的 2015 年 5 月，一封电子邮件被发送到了帕里斯岛新兵训练营。上面没有名字，作者自称是一名退役海军陆战队员和一位忧心忡忡的家长。信中写道：“我为写这封匿名邮件道歉，
but I do not want the drill instructors to mark my son for this email as he is unaware that I am sending this. I am afraid I am going to be one of the parents who is very concerned about the treatment that the new Marines underwent at Third Recruit Training Battalion. I confirmed with my friends who were DI's on Parris Island and they agreed that you need to be aware
但我不想让教官因为这封邮件而针对我的儿子，因为他不知道我在发送这封邮件。恐怕我将成为那些对第三新兵训练营的新海军陆战队员所受待遇感到非常担忧的家长之一。我与我在帕里斯岛担任教官的朋友确认过，他们同意你们需要意识到
of what is going on. The author went on to explain that his son had told him about his recent experiences while training. He and his fellow recruits had been told by their drill instructors that they didn't need blankets at night as they were only for decoration. In an attempt to stay warm in the freezing cold barracks, the recruits slept in extra clothing
正在发生的事情。”作者继续解释说，他的儿子在训练时告诉了他最近的经历。他和他的战友们被教官告知，他们晚上不需要毯子，因为毯子只是装饰品。为了在寒冷的营房里保持温暖，新兵们穿着额外的衣服睡觉，
and kept their hands tucked inside their shirts. One drill instructor in particular seemed to enjoy pushing recruits against a wall while choking their necks. The author's son had been shoved against the wall once and dislocated his shoulder. The recruits knew not to complain, having been told, what happens in Third Battalion stays in Third Battalion.
并把手塞进衬衫里。一位教官似乎特别喜欢把新兵推向墙壁，同时掐住他们的脖子。作者的儿子曾被推向墙壁一次，导致肩膀脱臼。新兵们知道不能抱怨，因为他们被告知：“发生在第三营的事就留在第三营。”
The author of the email clarified that he had been trained at Parris Island several decades earlier as had his own father before him, but neither of them had ever experienced the kind of hazing that current recruits seemed to be enduring. We both had hardcore DI's, but not once did they ever touch us. Their style of leadership was already intimidating enough
这封邮件的作者澄清说，他几十年前曾在帕里斯岛接受过训练，他的父亲在他之前也曾在此受训，但他们两人从未经历过当前新兵似乎正在忍受的那种欺凌。我们都有严厉的教官，但他们从未触碰过我们。他们的领导风格已经足够令人生畏，
to make us move and feel as if we earned the title Marine. The Third Battalion type of leadership will eventually lead to severe consequences for someone, which I am sure you are aware. 20-year-old Raheel Siddiqui was an unlikely Marine's recruit. The son of Pakistani immigrants, he had always been academically gifted rather than athletic. In his hometown of Taylor, Michigan,
足以让我们行动起来，并感觉我们赢得了“海军陆战队员”的称号。第三营的领导方式最终会导致某人付出惨重的代价，我相信你们对此很清楚。20 岁的拉希尔·西迪基（Raheel Siddiqui）是一个不太可能成为海军陆战队员的新兵。作为巴基斯坦移民的儿子，他一直是一个学术天才，而不是运动健将。在他的家乡密歇根州泰勒市，
he was a star student at Harry S. Truman High School. Raheel worked hard and barely socialized so that he could maintain perfect grades. He consulted his school's guidance counselor on what would be the most challenging classes to take. His dream was to study engineering at college. Raheel saw how hard his parents worked, his father at an auto parts factory,
他是哈里·S·杜鲁门高中的明星学生。拉希尔努力学习，几乎不参加社交活动，以便保持完美的成绩。他咨询了学校的指导顾问，了解哪些课程最具挑战性。他的梦想是在大学学习工程学。拉希尔看到了父母工作有多辛苦，父亲在汽车零部件工厂工作，
and his mother picking up odd jobs. He wanted to help support them too. When he graduated high school, Raheel was a valedictorian and ninth in his class overall. Raheel was accepted at multiple universities and was even offered a full scholarship to Michigan State. Then in April 2014, he found out that he'd been accepted at the University of Michigan-Dearborn,
母亲打零工。他也想帮助支持他们。高中毕业时，拉希尔是毕业典礼致辞代表，总成绩在班级中排名第九。拉希尔被多所大学录取，甚至获得了密歇根州立大学的全额奖学金。然后，在 2014 年 4 月，他发现自己被密歇根大学迪尔伯恩分校录取了，
a college with a robotics engineering program Raheel was particularly drawn to. They weren't providing a full scholarship, but were offering a $2,000 one as well as financial aid. This meant his parents wouldn't have to pay expensive college tuition as long as Raheel kept his grades above a C average. Raheel was ambitious and so decided to aim even higher. He enrolled in the college's honors program, which would require him to maintain a B average.
这是一所拥有拉希尔特别感兴趣的机器人工程项目的大学。他们没有提供全额奖学金，但提供了一笔 2,000 美元的奖学金以及经济援助。这意味着只要拉希尔保持成绩在 C 以上，他的父母就不必支付昂贵的大学学费。拉希尔很有抱负，所以决定目标更高。他报名参加了该学院的荣誉课程，这要求他保持 B 的平均成绩。
As well as studying hard, Raheel worked part-time on the service desk of a home depot store, a home improvement franchise. When he finished high school, he decided to work longer hours so he could provide his parents with financial support. Raheel wanted there to be enough money so his younger sister could one day go to college too. He started working 20 hours a week.
除了努力学习，拉希尔还在一家家居装修连锁店——家得宝（Home Depot）的服务台兼职工作。高中毕业后，他决定延长工作时间，以便为父母提供经济支持。拉希尔希望有足够的钱，这样他的妹妹将来也能上大学。他开始每周工作 20 小时。
Juggling work and study was harder than Raheel had anticipated. He began to feel stressed about the amount of pressure he was under to maintain top grades. By the end of his first semester, Raheel started getting Cs instead of the A's he was used to. In July 2015, the summer after Raheel's freshman year, he surprised his parents with an announcement. He was leaving college and enlisting with the Marines.
平衡工作和学习比拉希尔预期的要困难。他开始感到压力，因为他承受着保持优异成绩的压力。第一学期结束时，拉希尔开始拿到 C，而不是他习惯的 A。2015 年 7 月，拉希尔大一后的那个夏天，他用一个消息让父母感到惊讶。他要退学并加入海军陆战队。
His mother Ghazala and father Masoud were shocked. Raheel had never expressed any interest in a military and they couldn't understand why he was abandoning his long-held dream of being at college. He reassured them that this was a way that he could serve his country and would also allow him to achieve his dreams. Recruiters had told him that he could continue
他的母亲加扎拉（Ghazala）和父亲马苏德（Masoud）感到震惊。拉希尔从未表达过对军队的任何兴趣，他们无法理解他为什么要放弃长期以来上大学的梦想。他向他们保证，这是一种他可以为国家服务的方式，也将使他能够实现自己的梦想。招募人员告诉他，他可以继续
his studies while serving. Plus, he'd already chosen a technical specialty working on Marine aircraft which meant he probably wouldn't have to fight unless he wanted to. Down the track, his experience could even help him pursue a career with the FBI. Raheel described the chance to serve
他在服役期间的学习。此外，他已经选择了从事海军陆战队飞机工作的技术专业，这意味着除非他愿意，否则他可能不必上战场。未来，他的经验甚至可以帮助他追求联邦调查局（FBI）的职业生涯。拉希尔形容这个服务的机会
as a golden opportunity, adding, Raheel encouraged his worried mother to visit the Marines recruitment office in Taylor so she could speak to the recruiters herself. Ghazala did so and was reassured by the Marines that her son would be entirely safe. Recruiters were prevalent in the part of Michigan where the Siddiqui family lived.
是一个“黄金机会”，并补充说，拉希尔鼓励他担心的母亲去泰勒的海军陆战队招募办公室，这样她就可以亲自与招募人员交谈。加扎拉照做了，并得到了海军陆战队的保证，她的儿子将是完全安全的。招募人员在西迪基一家居住的密歇根州部分地区很普遍。
Located about 15 miles south-west of Detroit, Taylor was known as one of the Down River communities and there were three military recruiting stations in the area. When the state's auto manufacturing industry declined, so did the area's socioeconomic standing. In Taylor, 15% of residents live below the poverty line. For young people in need of a career,
泰勒位于底特律西南约 15 英里处，被称为“下游河”（Down River）社区之一，该地区有三个军事招募站。当该州的汽车制造业衰退时，该地区的社会经济地位也随之下降。在泰勒，15% 的居民生活在贫困线以下。对于需要职业的年轻人来说，
the military can be an appealing option. And for the Marines, highly intelligent, hard-working individuals such as Raheel Siddiqui are ideal recruits. By July 8, 2015, Raheel Siddiqui had signed his enlistment papers and began the Marines delayed entry program. The program would introduce Raheel
军队可能是一个有吸引力的选择。对于海军陆战队来说，像拉希尔·西迪基这样高智商、勤奋的个人是理想的新兵。到 2015 年 7 月 8 日，拉希尔·西迪基签署了他的入伍文件，并开始了海军陆战队的延迟入伍计划。该计划将向拉希尔介绍
to the Marines culture with meetings every Saturday. Embracing his new path wholeheartedly, Raheel began preparing for training. He woke up every morning at 4 a.m. to work out at the gym. He learned how to swim. He installed exercise equipment at home so he could also work out there and he began drinking protein shakes.
海军陆战队的文化，每周六举行会议。拉希尔全心全意地拥抱他的新道路，开始为训练做准备。他每天早上 4 点起床去健身房锻炼。他学会了游泳。他在家里安装了健身器材，这样他也可以在那里锻炼，并开始喝蛋白奶昔。
Raheel's family were astonished at the changes in him. He had always been academically driven, but now he was physically motivated as well. His recruiter told them how impressed he was by Raheel's work ethic. He was definitely the most driven recruit of the lot. Finally, after eight months, Raheel's time to attend boot camp at Parris Island arrived.
拉希尔的家人对他的变化感到惊讶。他一直有学术动力，但现在他也有了身体动力。他的招募人员告诉他们，他对拉希尔的职业道德印象深刻。他绝对是这批人中最有动力的新兵。终于，八个月后，拉希尔去帕里斯岛参加新兵训练营的时间到了。
His parents remained nervous. Raheel had never even stayed away from home for a single night before, and now he would be spending several months in a state with total strangers. Gazala Siddiqui had a nagging feeling that going away wasn't the right thing for her son. But when she asked him one last time
他的父母仍然很紧张。拉希尔以前甚至从未离开家过夜，现在他将在一个州与完全陌生的人一起度过几个月。加扎拉·西迪基有一种挥之不去的预感，认为离开并不是她儿子的正确选择。但当她最后一次问他
if he was 100% sure, he replied, No, Mum, it's okay. I made up my mind. I'm ready to go. Don't worry about me. He promised to adhere to the teachings of their Islamic faith while away and follow Muslim dietary requirements
是否 100% 确定时，他回答说：“不，妈妈，没关系。我已经下定决心了。我准备好走了。别担心我。”他承诺在离开期间遵守他们伊斯兰信仰的教义，并尽可能遵循穆斯林的饮食要求。
as best as possible. In February 2016, Raheel's colleagues at Home Depot threw him a goodbye party. They all knew Raheel as someone who was highly intelligent, but not the most street smart. Some were worried that his outlook was too positive. He was a kind person who couldn't conceive of anyone being unkind.
2016 年 2 月，拉希尔在家得宝的同事为他举办了欢送会。他们都知道拉希尔是一个非常聪明的人，但不是最精明的人。有些人担心他的前景太乐观了。他是一个善良的人，无法想象任何人会不友善。
One of his friends warned him, Be careful. Just watch yourself. You don't know what kinds of people are down there. You don't know how other people think. On Sunday, March 6, 2016, Raheel said goodbye to his parents and sister, promising to call when he arrived at Parris Island. For the next day, Ghazala and Masood
他的一个朋友警告他：“小心点。看着点自己。你不知道那里有什么样的人。你不知道别人是怎么想的。”2016 年 3 月 6 日星期日，拉希尔与父母和妹妹告别，承诺到达帕里斯岛后会打电话。接下来的日子里，加扎拉和马苏德
waited patiently for the phone to ring. Finally, late at night on Monday, March 7, it rang. Ghazala quickly answered it and was met with very strange sounds. It sounded like indescribable grunting and shouting set against a noisy background. After less than five seconds, the line went dead. Ghazala said her son's name, but there was no reply.
耐心地等待着电话响起。终于，在 3 月 7 日星期一深夜，电话响了。加扎拉迅速接听，听到了一些非常奇怪的声音。听起来像是嘈杂背景下难以形容的咕哝声和喊叫声。不到五秒钟后，线路就断了。加扎拉叫了她儿子的名字，但没有回应。
Ghazala was worried. The call hadn't sounded like Raheel at all. The next morning, she contacted Raheel's recruiter and shared her concerns, stating, No one knows my son's voice better than me. That didn't sound like my son. The recruiter reassured her that all was fine. Raheel had arrived safely at the base.
加扎拉很担心。电话听起来根本不像拉希尔。第二天早上，她联系了拉希尔的招募人员并分享了她的担忧，称：“没有人比我更了解我儿子的声音。那听起来不像我儿子。”招募人员向她保证一切都很好。拉希尔已经安全抵达基地。
He'd just sounded strange because he'd been reading the script that all recruits had to follow when they first called home and only had a few seconds to do it. But Ghazala Siddiqui couldn't shake the feeling that something was wrong. When Raheel Siddiqui arrived at Parris Island alongside around 4,000 other recruits
他听起来很奇怪，只是因为他一直在读所有新兵第一次给家里打电话时必须遵循的脚本，而且只有几秒钟的时间。但加扎拉·西迪基无法摆脱某种事情不对劲的感觉。当拉希尔·西迪基在 3 月 7 日星期一与其他约 4,000 名新兵一起抵达帕里斯岛时，
laid on Monday, March 7, he followed the same instructions that all new recruits followed. After four days of administrative tasks and strength tests, he was assigned to Platoon 3042 on Saturday, March 12. Platoon 3042 sat within Kilo Company in the 3rd Battalion. Kilo Company is known amongst the drill instructors and recruits as Killer Kilo, a nod to its intensity. Raheel and his 58 platoon mates were taken to their squad bay.
他遵循了所有新兵都遵循的相同指示。经过四天的行政任务和力量测试，他于 3 月 12 日星期六被分配到 3042 排。3042 排位于第三营的 Kilo 连。Kilo 连在教官和新兵中被称为“杀手 Kilo”（Killer Kilo），这是对其强度的致敬。拉希尔和他的 58 名排友被带到了他们的宿舍。
It sat on the 3rd floor of its building and was about 60 yards long and 15 yards wide. Two long rows of bunk beds flanked two walls with a wide aisle down the middle. The recruits were instructed to sit cross-legged on the floor. Their senior drill instructor introduced himself. It was Gunnery Sergeant Joseph Felix who had been reassigned from the platoon he'd had the previous year.
它位于大楼的三楼，长约 60 码，宽约 15 码。两排长长的双层床靠着两面墙，中间有一条宽阔的过道。新兵们被指示盘腿坐在地板上。他们的高级教官介绍了自己。他就是炮兵军士约瑟夫·费利克斯，他从前一年所在的排被重新分配过来。
Speaking in a harsh, authoritative tone, Felix promised to treat his new recruits with firmness, fairness, dignity and compassion. Under no circumstances would abuse be tolerated. Then the real training began. Recruits had to jump on each other in a dog pile then run back and forth. They were made to do hundreds of burpees,
费利克斯用严厉、权威的语气承诺以坚定、公平、尊严和同情心对待他的新兵。在任何情况下都不会容忍虐待。然后真正的训练开始了。新兵们必须跳到彼此身上堆成一堆，然后来回奔跑。他们被迫做数百个波比跳（burpees），
a full body exercise where they dropped to a push-up then jumped in the air. They had to dangle their rifles from their little fingers. Even the extremely fit recruits found it excruciating. One later told journalist Janet Reitman of the New York Times that he thought he would pass out. Another recruit had a panic attack and started vomiting. At first, officers were supervising from the back of the room.
这是一种全身运动，即先做一个俯卧撑，然后跳向空中。他们必须用小指悬挂步枪。即使是身体极其强壮的新兵也觉得这非常痛苦。一位新兵后来告诉《纽约时报》记者珍妮特·雷特曼，他以为自己会昏倒。另一名新兵惊恐发作并开始呕吐。起初，军官们在房间后面监督。
After they left, the drill instructors only intensified the training. The next morning at 7.20am, the recruits had already been up and training for several hours when Raheel Siddiqui reported that he wanted to die. His instructors pushed back against this, asking him what his mother would think if he left before finishing training. Raheel replied, I'd tell my mother goodbye and kill myself.
他们离开后，教官们只会加强训练。第二天早上 7 点 20 分，新兵们已经起床训练了几个小时，拉希尔·西迪基报告说他想死。他的教官们对此进行了反击，问他如果他在完成训练前离开，他的母亲会怎么想。拉希尔回答说：“我会告诉妈妈再见，然后自杀。”
The future does not matter. This recruit is going to kill himself. He'd even figured out how he would do it. He would jump from the squad bay window. Realising that they were dealing with a suicide threat, the drill instructors confiscated Raheel's belt and the laces from his boots. Military police were summoned and arrived within minutes. As it wasn't unusual for recruits to threaten self-harm in the early days of their training,
“未来不重要。这个新兵要自杀。”他甚至想好了他会怎么做。他会从宿舍的窗户跳下去。意识到他们正在处理自杀威胁，教官们没收了拉希尔的腰带和靴子上的鞋带。宪兵被传唤，并在几分钟内赶到。由于新兵在训练初期威胁自残并不罕见，
the Marines had a strict protocol they followed. When the military police spoke with Raheel, he elaborated on what had upset him. He couldn't handle drill instructors yelling at him and hitting him. The instructors dismissed Raheel's claims. They hadn't hit him, they had only touched him when they had to provide corrections, such as fixing his uniform or position. Drill instructors were barred from touching recruits in all situations, except to drill corrections. It was determined that Raheel should remain on the base under Suicide Watch.
海军陆战队有一套严格的协议。当宪兵与拉希尔交谈时，他详细说明了让他心烦意乱的原因。他无法忍受教官对他大喊大叫并打他。教官们驳回了拉希尔的说法。他们没有打他，只有在必须提供纠正时才触碰他，例如整理他的制服或姿势。教官在所有情况下都被禁止触碰新兵，除非是进行纠正训练。最终决定拉希尔应留在基地接受自杀监视。
Recruits were only transported off base for treatment if they had actually self-harmed or attempted suicide. Raheel was moved to another platoon's squad bay and was told to sit on a mattress in the middle of the room. He sat there for 24 hours while other recruits took it in turns to watch over him. When night fell, they shone a torch into his face in order to keep an eye on him. Eventually, Raheel spoke up and said he'd changed his mind. He didn't want to die at all. He wanted to continue training and become a Marine. The next morning, Raheel's senior drill instructor, Gunnery Sergeant Joseph Felix, took Raheel to recruit liaison services to discuss the previous day's events with a higher up.
只有在实际自残或企图自杀的情况下，新兵才会被送出基地接受治疗。拉希尔被转移到另一个排的宿舍，并被告知坐在房间中间的床垫上。他在那里坐了 24 小时，其他新兵轮流看守他。夜幕降临时，他们用手电筒照向他的脸，以便监视他。最终，拉希尔开口说他改变了主意。他根本不想死。他想继续训练并成为一名海军陆战队员。第二天早上，拉希尔的高级教官，炮兵军士约瑟夫·费利克斯，带拉希尔去新兵联络处与上级讨论前一天发生的事情。
Usually drill instructors waited outside for recruits for meetings like this, but Felix stayed in the office throughout about 10 feet away from Raheel. Raheel explained that he had no intention of killing himself and had no history of mental health problems. He had only said that because he wanted the training to stop. This recruit thought it was the only way to quit. The recruit never meant that and regrets it. Raheel was dismissed as a low risk for self-harm and returned to his platoon. Over the next few days, the recruits continued training. They had to perform sprints and cross-country runs.
通常教官会在外面等新兵参加这样的会议，但费利克斯一直待在办公室里，距离拉希尔大约 10 英尺。拉希尔解释说他没有自杀的意图，也没有心理健康问题的病史。他之所以那样说，只是因为他想停止训练。这个新兵认为这是退出的唯一途径。该新兵从未那样想过，并对此感到后悔。拉希尔被认为自残风险较低，并回到了他的排。在接下来的几天里，新兵们继续训练。他们必须进行短跑和越野跑。
They were taught mixed martial arts, bayonet techniques and close-order drills. During one routine focused on punching, recruits were split into pairs and instructed to punch one another repeatedly. Many of the larger, stronger recruits were teamed up with smaller individuals. They were told not to listen to their DI's instructions just to keep punching. Many recruits were hidden their jaws. One suffered broken ribs, another broke down in tears. Drill instructors would refer to their recruits as maggots, pussies and a variety of sexist and homophobic slurs.
他们学习了综合格斗、刺刀技术和队列训练。在一次专注于出拳的例行训练中，新兵们被分成两人一组，并被指示反复击打对方。许多体型较大、较强壮的新兵与体型较小的人配对。他们被告知不要听教官的指示，只需继续出拳。许多新兵被打得下巴受伤。一人肋骨骨折，另一人泪流满面。教官们会称呼他们的新兵为“蛆虫”、“懦夫”，以及各种性别歧视和恐同的侮辱性词汇。
Some were targeted for their personal attributes such as their ethnicity. Drill instructors themselves weren't immune from abuse either. Senior DI's would often yell at their subordinates who in turn took out their anger on recruits. After Gunnery Sergeant Joseph Felix shouted at one DI, he began screaming at his recruits to the extent that he became sick and vomited across the floor. One of Raheel Siddiqui's platoon mates noticed that Raheel seemed baffled by being asked to follow orders. Following orders was crucial to being in the Marines, but Raheel seemed to query why he was being told to do certain things.
有些人因个人属性（如种族）而成为目标。教官们自己也无法免受虐待。高级教官经常对下属大喊大叫，下属反过来又把愤怒发泄在新兵身上。在炮兵军士约瑟夫·费利克斯对一名教官大喊大叫后，他开始对他的新兵尖叫，以至于他生病并呕吐在地板上。拉希尔·西迪基的一名排友注意到，拉希尔似乎对被要求服从命令感到困惑。服从命令对于成为海军陆战队员至关重要，但拉希尔似乎质疑为什么他被告知要做某些事情。
His platoon mate wondered why he had enlisted and later told the New York Times that Raheel always looked like a scared animal. At about 2am on Friday March 18, the recruit who shared Raheel's bunk was woken by Raheel. He wanted to talk to him, explaining that he was in pain. Where all in pain, his bunk mate replied before turning over to go back to sleep. Two hours later it was time for the recruits to get up. By 4.15 they were lined up to go to breakfast. A drill instructor told them to sound off before they left, a term used for the call Marines are required to give in response to an order.
他的排友想知道他为什么要入伍，后来告诉《纽约时报》，拉希尔看起来总是像一只受惊的动物。3 月 18 日星期五凌晨 2 点左右，与拉希尔共用一张床铺的新兵被拉希尔叫醒。他想和他谈谈，解释说他很痛苦。“我们都很痛苦，”他的床友回答，然后翻身继续睡觉。两个小时后，新兵们该起床了。到 4 点 15 分，他们排队去吃早餐。一名教官告诉他们在离开前“报数”（sound off），这是海军陆战队员在响应命令时被要求发出的呼喊。
All except Raheel obeyed. Two DI's noticed and began to yell at him for disobeying orders. When one approached Raheel and demanded he sound off, Raheel pointed at his throat and silently passed him a note. It read, This recruit has to go to medical. This recruits throat has been swollen for three days and is getting worse. This recruit also coughed blood a few times last night, and this recruit completely lost his voice and can barely whisper.
除了拉希尔，所有人都服从了。两名教官注意到了，并开始对他不服从命令大喊大叫。当其中一人接近拉希尔并要求他报数时，拉希尔指着自己的喉咙，默默地递给他一张纸条。上面写着：“这个新兵必须去医疗单位。这个新兵的喉咙已经肿了三天，而且越来越严重。这个新兵昨晚还咳了几次血，而且这个新兵完全失去了声音，几乎只能耳语。”
This recruits whole neck is in a lot of pain. The drill instructor told Raheel they'd sought him out after breakfast. In the meantime Raheel would have to go to the mess hall with the rest of his platoon. At breakfast a drill instructor asked for Raheel's help passing out cups. Raheel ignored him. He sat quietly as the rest of the platoon ate, staring into space. By 5.30 am the platoon was back at their barracks doing some cleaning. Raheel was ordered to the front of the squad bay so he could fill out a form to go to the medical unit.
“这个新兵的整个脖子都很痛。”教官告诉拉希尔，他们早餐后会找他。在此期间，拉希尔必须和排里的其他人一起去食堂。早餐时，一名教官要求拉希尔帮忙分发杯子。拉希尔无视了他。他静静地坐着，看着排里的其他人吃饭，盯着虚空。到早上 5 点 30 分，排里回到了营房进行清理。拉希尔被命令到宿舍前面，以便他可以填写表格去医疗单位。
When Raheel approached senior drill instructor Joseph Felix, Raheel didn't address him as was required, presumably due to his sore throat. Instead he stood there silently. Felix became angry and demanded Raheel run get-backs across the squad bay. This involved sprinting back and forth across the length of the room until told to stop. Exercise such as this was known as incentive training. Raheel did as he was told while holding his throat as Felix continued to shout, Siddiqui run get-back run I don't care what's wrong with you you're going to say something back to me.
当拉希尔接近高级教官约瑟夫·费利克斯时，拉希尔没有按照要求称呼他，大概是因为他喉咙痛。相反，他默默地站在那里。费利克斯变得愤怒，并要求拉希尔在宿舍里跑“折返跑”（get-backs）。这包括在房间长度上来回冲刺，直到被告知停止。这种运动被称为“激励训练”。拉希尔照做了，同时捂着喉咙，而费利克斯继续大喊：“西迪基，跑折返跑，跑！我不在乎你怎么了，你得回我话。”
The other recruits kept cleaning quietly as Raheel ran back and forth across the squad bay. Then suddenly Raheel clutched his throat and fell to the floor crying. He lay there motionless his hands still wrapped around his neck. Get up Siddiqui I know you're faking yelled Felix get up. Get up. He walked over to Raheel and slapped him across the face. Raheel's head turned to one side but otherwise he didn't move. Felix slapped him again.
其他新兵安静地继续清理，而拉希尔在宿舍里来回奔跑。然后突然，拉希尔捂住喉咙，哭着倒在地板上。他躺在那里一动不动，双手仍然紧紧抓着脖子。“起来，西迪基，我知道你在装模作样，”费利克斯大喊，“起来。起来。”他走到拉希尔身边，扇了他一巴掌。拉希尔的头转向一边，但除此之外他没有动。费利克斯又扇了他一巴掌。
He did it so forcefully that the sound echoed across the enormous squad bay. Raheel stood up holding his face and began running again. One of his platoon mates thought it was the fastest he'd ever seen anyone run before. It looked as though Raheel was completing the get-backs he'd been ordered to do. But then he kept running to the back of the room where a set of double doors led to an external staircase. Raheel pushed the doors open and hoisted himself up on the railing of the stairway. Then his feet caught on the metal rail and he tumbled over the side. At 5.35am a marine who happened to be outside passing by saw Raheel's body fall from the third floor and hit the concrete below.
他用力之大，声音在巨大的宿舍区回荡。拉希尔捂着脸站起来，又开始奔跑。他的一名排友认为这是他见过跑得最快的一次。看起来拉希尔是在完成被命令做的折返跑。但随后他继续跑到房间后面，那里有一组双开门通向外部楼梯。拉希尔推开门，把自己拉到楼梯的栏杆上。接着他的脚被金属栏杆绊住，翻过了侧面。凌晨5点35分，一名恰好路过的海军陆战队员看到拉希尔的身体从三楼坠落，撞击在下方的混凝土上。
The marine called 911 and reported, I got a recruit that fell from the third deck. Meanwhile up in the squad bay Raheel's shocked platoon mates were ordered to file into the bathroom and face the wall. While Raheel was being given first aid they were taken to complete their usual training schedule. Drill instructors warned them not to talk about what they'd seen. Raheel had suffered severe blunt force trauma but was still alive. An air ambulance was requested to take him to a hospital 40 miles away. Due to heavy fog an airlift wasn't possible so the Marines drove Raheel to Beaufort Memorial Hospital.
这名海军陆战队员拨打了911并报告说，我有一名新兵从三楼掉下来了。与此同时，在宿舍区，拉希尔震惊的排友们被命令排队进入浴室并面对墙壁。在拉希尔接受急救时，他们被带去完成日常训练计划。教官警告他们不要谈论所见之事。拉希尔遭受了严重的钝器伤，但仍有生命体征。一架空中救护车被要求将他送往40英里外的医院。由于大雾，空运无法实现，海军陆战队便开车将拉希尔送往博福特纪念医院。
For an hour emergency room doctors worked on Raheel. They realized that he needed a more specialized form of care so he was transferred to another hospital in Charleston. Gazala Siddiqui hadn't stopped worrying about her son since he left home for boot camp. She'd only had one bizarre phone call from him and hadn't been able to talk to him at all. At 7pm on Friday March 18, a week and a half after that call, there was a knock on the front door of the Siddiqui residence. Gazala answered the door to see two Marines standing outside. Gazala assumed they must be there to share some good news about her son's achievements at training. The thought was a relief.
急诊室医生为拉希尔抢救了一个小时。他们意识到他需要更专业的护理，于是将他转院到查尔斯顿的另一家医院。加扎拉·西迪基自从儿子离家去新兵训练营后就一直担心不已。她只接到过他一个奇怪的电话，之后就再也没能和他通话。3月18日星期五晚上7点，也就是那通电话后的一个半星期，西迪基家的前门被敲响了。加扎拉开门看到两名海军陆战队员站在外面。加扎拉以为他们一定是来分享关于她儿子在训练中取得成就的好消息的。这个想法让她感到宽慰。
She had been worried about Raheel since he'd gone away to the extent that she'd struggled to sleep at night. Gazala invited the Marines inside. The two officers stepped inside and asked if everyone was at home. Gazala said that she and her daughter Sidra were there but her husband Masoud was at work. One of the officers stepped back outside and made a brief phone call. As he was talking, Sidra overheard him say, The dad's not home now, should I still say it? Sidra was confused and couldn't understand what was happening.
自从拉希尔离开后，她一直很担心，以至于晚上难以入睡。加扎拉邀请海军陆战队员进屋。两名军官走进屋内，询问是否所有家人都在家。加扎拉说她和女儿西德拉在家，但丈夫马苏德在上班。其中一名军官退到外面，打了一个简短的电话。在他通话时，西德拉无意中听到他说，父亲现在不在家，我还要说吗？西德拉感到困惑，无法理解发生了什么。
The officer returned and said to Gazala, Ma'am, I have bad news. Your son passed away. In total disbelief, Gazala replied, No, no, no. You're wrong. You're wrong. Something is wrong. Then she cried out for Sidra to call her father before fainting. When Gazala woke, she was in the hospital being treated for shock. Despite the best efforts of doctors in South Carolina, Raheel had been pronounced dead at 10.06am, four and a half hours after his fall. His death was ruled a suicide.
那名军官回来后对加扎拉说，女士，我有坏消息。你的儿子去世了。加扎拉完全不相信，回答说，不，不，不。你错了。你错了。一定是哪里搞错了。然后她哭喊着让西德拉叫她父亲，随后昏倒了。当加扎拉醒来时，她正在医院接受休克治疗。尽管南卡罗来纳州的医生尽了最大努力，拉希尔还是在上午10点06分被宣布死亡，距离他坠楼过去了四个半小时。他的死被裁定为自杀。
Almost a week later on Thursday, March 24, Raheel's body was flown home to Michigan in a coffin draped with an American flag. When the Siddiqi family viewed his body at the funeral home, they were horrified by what they saw. There were ligature marks around his neck, and most of his body had a purpleish hue. When the family read Raheel's autopsy report, they noticed that in addition to the blunt force trauma, the forensic pathologist found evidence of particular hemorrhaging. This could be caused by heavy coughing or vomiting, or even strangulation. Despite the coroner's ruling of suicide, the Siddiqi's couldn't believe Raheel had taken his own life. They felt his devotion to his parents would make it impossible for him to do so, as well as his Islamic faith, which considered suicide a sin.
近一周后的3月24日星期四，拉希尔的遗体被运回密歇根州，棺材上覆盖着美国国旗。当西迪基一家在殡仪馆瞻仰他的遗体时，他们被所见景象惊呆了。他的脖子上有勒痕，大部分身体呈紫红色。当家人阅读拉希尔的尸检报告时，他们注意到除了钝器伤外，法医病理学家还发现了点状出血的证据。这可能是由剧烈咳嗽、呕吐甚至勒颈引起的。尽管验尸官裁定为自杀，但西迪基一家无法相信拉希尔会自杀。他们认为他对父母的孝顺使他不可能这样做，而且他的伊斯兰信仰也将自杀视为罪孽。
Certain there was more to the situation than met the eye, they retained a lawyer to advocate on their behalf. When officials interviewed the Siddiqi's, they confirmed that Raheel had no history of mental illness. He had always been well-behaved with a mischievous sense of humour, and their memory of him was as a son who smiled all the time. Upon hearing the story of how Raheel had died, the Siddiqi's and their lawyer were unsettled. They couldn't understand how so many witnesses in the squad bay had seen Raheel collapse and be slapped by Felix, yet only one individual had detailed how he had fallen. An investigation into Raheel's death began. It was coordinated by the Paris Island Office of the Naval Criminal Investigative Service, also known as NCIS. While they were adamant that there were no indications of foul play, they still wanted to gain a full understanding of the events that led up to Raheel's death.
他们确信情况远非表面看起来那么简单，于是聘请了一名律师代表他们。当官员采访西迪基一家时，他们证实拉希尔没有精神疾病史。他一直表现良好，有着调皮的幽默感，在他们的记忆中，他是一个总是面带微笑的儿子。在听到拉希尔死亡的经过后，西迪基一家和他们的律师感到不安。他们无法理解为什么宿舍区有那么多目击者看到拉希尔倒下并被菲利克斯扇耳光，却只有一个人详细描述了他坠楼的过程。针对拉希尔死亡的调查开始了。调查由海军刑事调查局（NCIS）的帕里斯岛办公室协调。虽然他们坚称没有迹象表明存在谋杀，但他们仍希望全面了解导致拉希尔死亡的事件。
Although the investigation would look at Paris Island as a whole, it was primarily focused on the third recruit training battalion. Much of the investigation's focus was on gunnery Sergeant Joseph Felix, who had been Raheel's senior drill instructor. Aged in his 30s, Felix had enlisted in the Marines in 2002. During his 14 years of service, he had worked as an air traffic controller and was deployed to the Iraq and Afghanistan wars. His time there left a lasting impact on him. Felix would rant to other Marines about how he hated Muslims, blaming them for killing friends who'd served alongside him. While it is unclear whether Joseph Felix suffered PTSD following his service in war zones, one officer told the New York Times he had a reputation for being, quote, pretty freaking psycho. One of the more aggressive drill instructors in his company, he even scared recruits who weren't in his platoon.
虽然调查将审视整个帕里斯岛，但重点主要集中在第三新兵训练营。调查的大部分焦点集中在炮兵中士约瑟夫·菲利克斯身上，他是拉希尔的高级教官。菲利克斯30多岁，于2002年加入海军陆战队。在他14年的服役期间，他曾担任空中交通管制员，并被派往伊拉克和阿富汗战争。在那里的经历对他产生了持久的影响。菲利克斯会向其他海军陆战队员抱怨他有多讨厌穆斯林，指责他们杀害了与他并肩作战的朋友。虽然不清楚约瑟夫·菲利克斯在战区服役后是否患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），但一名军官告诉《纽约时报》，他以“相当疯狂”而闻名。作为连队里最激进的教官之一，他甚至吓坏了不在他排里的新兵。
One recruit who'd been training in Raheel Siddiqui's cohort saw Felix push another recruit into a footlocker. Others were choked or thrown against walls. On one occasion, Felix forced a recruit to only eat jelly and mashed potatoes for several days. And it appeared that Felix had a history of singling out Muslim recruits in particular. In 2015, the year before Raheel Siddiqui began training, Felix had repeatedly tormented a young Muslim from Brooklyn named Amir Bormash. As well as accusing him of being a terrorist spy, Felix forced Amir into an industrial dryer, then turned it on. And Amir wasn't the only victim. That same year, Felix honed in on a 19-year-old named Rakan Harvez.
一名在拉希尔·西迪基同批次训练的新兵看到菲利克斯把另一名新兵推入储物柜。其他人则被掐住脖子或被扔向墙壁。有一次，菲利克斯强迫一名新兵连续几天只吃果冻和土豆泥。而且菲利克斯似乎有专门针对穆斯林新兵的历史。2015年，也就是拉希尔·西迪基开始训练的前一年，菲利克斯曾多次折磨一名来自布鲁克林的年轻穆斯林阿米尔·博马什。除了指责他是恐怖分子间谍外，菲利克斯还强迫阿米尔进入工业烘干机，然后将其打开。阿米尔并不是唯一的受害者。同年，菲利克斯盯上了一名19岁的年轻人拉坎·哈维兹。
Rakan had immigrated to the United States from Kurdistan with his family as a baby. Felix nicknamed Rakan terrorist, ISIS, and Kurdish. Like Amir, Rakan was forced into a dryer by Felix, although he didn't switch it on. Despite the ethos of what happens in 3rd Battalion stays in 3rd Battalion, these incidents hadn't gone unreported. When recruit Jake Weaver was told in 2015 that he would be receiving an other-than-honorable discharge from the Marines, his father decided to step in. Troy Weaver had been told by his son about the abuses that had gone on at Parris Island. It seemed incredibly unfair that Jake would be receiving a bad discharge after what he'd seen and experienced. Troy Weaver contacted Jake's commanding officer and shared what he knew.
拉坎婴儿时期随家人从库尔德斯坦移民到美国。菲利克斯给拉坎起了“恐怖分子”、“ISIS”和“库尔德人”等绰号。像阿米尔一样，拉坎也被菲利克斯强迫进入烘干机，尽管他没有打开开关。尽管有“第三营发生的事就留在第三营”的潜规则，但这些事件并非没有被举报。当新兵杰克·韦弗在2015年被告知他将因非荣誉退伍而离开海军陆战队时，他的父亲决定介入。特洛伊·韦弗从儿子那里得知了帕里斯岛发生的虐待事件。在经历了所见所闻后，杰克被非荣誉退伍显得极其不公平。特洛伊·韦弗联系了杰克的指挥官，并分享了他所知道的情况。
This got the ball rolling. A code of silence had prevented recruits from speaking up earlier, but after Troy Weaver reached out, the Marines opened an investigation into the allegations on November 5, 2015. Jake Weaver provided a statement, as did Amir Bormash. Two months later, the findings were submitted. The training regiments' executive officer found the evidence compelling enough for the drill instructors involved to be stood down from their duties, including Joseph Felix. But no action followed. Four months later, Joseph Felix was given the role of senior drill instructor for Platoon 3042. Rahil Siddiqui, a Pakistani-American Muslim, was assigned to this platoon, despite Felix's history of abusing Islamic recruits.
这推动了事情的发展。沉默准则曾阻止新兵早些时候发声，但在特洛伊·韦弗联系后，海军陆战队于2015年11月5日对这些指控展开了调查。杰克·韦弗提供了陈述，阿米尔·博马什也提供了陈述。两个月后，调查结果被提交。训练团的执行官认为证据足以让相关教官停职，包括约瑟夫·菲利克斯。但随后没有采取任何行动。四个月后，约瑟夫·菲利克斯被任命为3042排的高级教官。拉希尔·西迪基，一名巴基斯坦裔美国穆斯林，被分配到这个排，尽管菲利克斯有虐待伊斯兰新兵的历史。
On Thursday, March 17, 2016, an individual involved in the 2015 hazing investigation contacted the investigating officer to suggest more witnesses be interviewed. An email had just arrived from someone corroborating some of the most serious allegations. The following day was the day that Rahil died. Many of the recruits from Rahil's platoon noticed how Gunnery Sergeant Joseph Felix seemed to single Rahil out. Some heard him call Rahil a terrorist again and again in a completely serious tone. One recruit estimated that in just a few days of training, Felix addressed Rahil as a terrorist more than 10 times. In one meeting, he told Rahil that he smelled like a terrorist. At another, Felix asked the recruits if any of them knew what a bazaar was.
2016年3月17日星期四，一名参与2015年欺凌调查的人员联系了调查官，建议采访更多证人。一封来自某人的电子邮件刚刚送达，证实了一些最严重的指控。第二天就是拉希尔去世的日子。拉希尔排里的许多新兵注意到炮兵中士约瑟夫·菲利克斯似乎专门针对拉希尔。有些人听到他以完全严肃的语气一遍又一遍地称拉希尔为恐怖分子。一名新兵估计，在短短几天的训练中，菲利克斯称呼拉希尔为恐怖分子的次数超过10次。在一次会议上，他告诉拉希尔他闻起来像个恐怖分子。在另一次会议上，菲利克斯问新兵们是否有人知道什么是集市。
Rahil said that he did. Of course you do, you goddamn terrorist, Felix replied. He also asked him if he needed his turban. At least one of the other recruits noticed that Rahil seemed reluctant to obey Felix's commands after being spoken to this way. Just the day after joining Felix's platoon, Rahil mentioned wanting to kill himself. Felix attended a meeting where Rahil discussed what he'd said, even though it was usual protocol for drill instructors to wait outside such meetings. Reports as to what exactly occurred in the immediate lead-up to Rahil's death were mixed. Some of his platoon mates who'd witnessed Felix reprimanding him said Felix had ordered Rahil to run while choking his own throat.
拉希尔说他知道。菲利克斯回答说，你当然知道，你这个该死的恐怖分子。他还问他是否需要他的头巾。至少有一名其他新兵注意到，在被这样对待后，拉希尔似乎不愿服从菲利克斯的命令。就在加入菲利克斯排的第二天，拉希尔提到了想自杀。菲利克斯参加了一次会议，会上拉希尔讨论了他所说的话，尽管教官在这些会议外等待是通常的规程。关于拉希尔死亡前夕究竟发生了什么，报道不一。一些目睹菲利克斯训斥他的排友说，菲利克斯命令拉希尔在掐住自己喉咙的同时奔跑。
Others thought Rahil was holding his throat because it was sore. One witness said he'd seen Felix throw Rahil to the floor. The others all believed Rahil had collapsed on his own. Everyone agreed that Felix had slapped Rahil, but some thought he did so only once to revive him. Others said Felix slapped him hard two or three times. After that, Rahil had leapt up and sprinted out of the squad bay and over a stairwell. He died just five days after being assigned to Felix's platoon. On Thursday, September 8, 2016, six months after Rahil's death, the Marines released a 133-page report about the matter and other allegations of abuse.
其他人认为拉希尔捂着喉咙是因为喉咙痛。一名目击者说他看到菲利克斯把拉希尔扔到地板上。其他人则认为拉希尔是自己倒下的。每个人都同意菲利克斯扇了拉希尔耳光，但有些人认为他只是扇了一次以唤醒他。其他人则说菲利克斯用力扇了他两三次。在那之后，拉希尔跳起来冲出了宿舍区，越过了楼梯间。他在被分配到菲利克斯排仅五天后就去世了。2016年9月8日星期四，在拉希尔去世六个月后，海军陆战队发布了一份关于此事及其他虐待指控的133页报告。
Much of it was redacted, with 40 pages completely blacked out. Nevertheless, it was clear the Marines had concluded that the actions of Joseph Felix directly led to Rahil jumping from the building. They also stated that Felix should never have been assigned to Rahil's platoon, given he was already under investigation for harassing another Muslim recruit. It was recommended that Felix be charged with assault for slapping Rahil. The report also focused on incidents involving other recruits being choked and forced to engage in unauthorized incentive training. It found Marines working as drill instructors had been operating with impunity without the proper supervision or leadership. 20 Marines were relieved of duty in the wake of the investigation, including three teams of drill instructors and the depot's regimental commander. Four were charged for incidents of abuse unrelated to Rahil Siddiqui.
其中大部分内容被删减，有40页完全涂黑。尽管如此，很明显海军陆战队得出的结论是，约瑟夫·菲利克斯的行为直接导致了拉希尔从楼上跳下。他们还指出，鉴于菲利克斯已经在接受骚扰另一名穆斯林新兵的调查，他不应该被分配到拉希尔的排。建议以扇拉希尔耳光为由对菲利克斯提出袭击指控。报告还重点关注了涉及其他新兵被掐脖子和被迫进行未经授权的惩罚性训练的事件。报告发现，担任教官的海军陆战队员在没有适当监督或领导的情况下肆无忌惮地行事。调查后，20名海军陆战队员被免职，包括三组教官和基地的团长。四人因与拉希尔·西迪基无关的虐待事件受到指控。
Joseph Felix was charged with failure to obey a general order, cruelty and maltreatment, making a false statement, and drunk and disorderly conduct. Rahil's family were disappointed with the charges. They didn't understand why Felix wasn't charged with assault, as the report had recommended. Joseph Felix was ordered to face a military trial, which began in November 2017. The trial would not center on the death of Rahil Siddiqui, but focus on numerous allegations regarding Felix's treatment of recruits. The prosecution called almost 70 witnesses to the stand. Other drill instructors testified about behavior they'd witnessed from Felix. Various recruits spoke of him choking them, hitting them against walls and forcing them to hurt one another. The prosecution also detailed how Felix had seemingly targeted Muslim recruits, describing his actions as hate crimes. Amir Bormesh and Rakan Haverz spoke of how Felix had abused them for being Muslim, with both of them being forced into industrial dryers.
约瑟夫·菲利克斯被控不服从一般命令、残忍和虐待、作虚假陈述以及醉酒和扰乱治安。拉希尔的家人对这些指控感到失望。他们不明白为什么菲利克斯没有像报告建议的那样被控袭击罪。约瑟夫·菲利克斯被命令接受军事审判，审判于2017年11月开始。审判的重点不是拉希尔·西迪基的死亡，而是关于菲利克斯对待新兵的众多指控。检方传唤了近70名证人出庭。其他教官作证说他们目睹了菲利克斯的行为。多名新兵讲述了他掐他们、把他们撞向墙壁并强迫他们互相伤害。检方还详细描述了菲利克斯似乎如何针对穆斯林新兵，将其行为描述为仇恨犯罪。阿米尔·博马什和拉坎·哈维兹讲述了菲利克斯如何因为他们是穆斯林而虐待他们，两人都被强迫进入工业烘干机。
Amir said Felix had tumbled him in the dryer for up to 30 seconds at a time. An expert on industrial dryers confirmed that a model such as the one in the 3rd Battalion's laundry was large enough to hold and tumble a recruit weighing up to 168 pounds. The defence only called one expert witness a burns expert. She said that in 30 seconds the dryer would have reached temperatures over 300 degrees Fahrenheit or 149 degrees Celsius. This would have caused third or fourth degree burns within one second, yet Amir had no physical evidence of burns. However, the expert did acknowledge that shorter durations could still cause pain without leaving visible injuries, adding, If I were in a dryer, 3 seconds would seem like an eternity. Although some said Felix spoke openly about his dislike of Muslims, Felix's lawyer insisted that his client hadn't specifically targeted Muslim recruits.
阿米尔说菲利克斯曾让他一次在烘干机里翻滚长达30秒。一位工业烘干机专家证实，像第三营洗衣房里的那种型号，大到足以容纳并翻滚一名重达168磅的新兵。辩方只传唤了一名专家证人，即烧伤专家。她说，在30秒内，烘干机的温度将达到华氏300度（149摄氏度）以上。这会在一秒钟内导致三度或四度烧伤，但阿米尔身上没有烧伤的物理证据。然而，专家确实承认，较短的时间仍然可能在不留下可见伤害的情况下造成疼痛，并补充说，如果我在烘干机里，3秒钟似乎就像永恒。虽然有人说菲利克斯公开谈论他对穆斯林的厌恶，但菲利克斯的律师坚称他的客户并没有专门针对穆斯林新兵。
He had only discussed the Islamic faith with Amir out of curiosity, and he had chosen Rakan Haverz to be squad leader after discovering he was Muslim. Some witnesses suggested that Felix had only called Muslim recruits terrorists as a joke and hadn't meant anything by it at all. The eight-person jury made up of male Marines spent a day deliberating before reaching a verdict. They found Felix guilty of eight counts of violating training orders regarding multiple recruits, including slapping Raheel and forcing him to sprint laps while sick. But he was found not guilty of referring to Raheel as a terrorist. Felix was also convicted for being drunk and disorderly and making false official statements. But he was cleared of obstructing justice for supposedly telling recruits to conceal information about what happened to Raheel. During his sentencing, Joseph Felix addressed the court.
他只是出于好奇与阿米尔讨论了伊斯兰信仰，并且在发现拉坎·哈维兹是穆斯林后选择他担任班长。一些证人暗示，菲利克斯称穆斯林新兵为恐怖分子只是开玩笑，根本没有恶意。由八名男性海军陆战队员组成的陪审团在达成裁决前审议了一天。他们认定菲利克斯犯有八项违反训练命令的罪名，涉及多名新兵，包括扇拉希尔耳光和强迫他在生病时进行冲刺跑。但他被判无罪，罪名是称拉希尔为恐怖分子。菲利克斯还因醉酒和扰乱治安以及作虚假官方陈述而被定罪。但他被免除了妨碍司法的指控，因为他被指控告诉新兵隐瞒关于拉希尔身上发生的事情的信息。在量刑期间，约瑟夫·菲利克斯向法庭发表了讲话。
He apologized to his wife, stating, Thank you for standing by me and being as wonderful as you are. I can never repay the disappointment I feel you have in me. He did not apologize to the Siddiqui family or the other recruits he had abused, nor did he acknowledge any of the charges he'd been convicted of. Felix's attorney asked that his client only serve 30 days in prison while the prosecution asked for seven years. He was sentenced to 10 years. His rank would also be reduced. He would have to forfeit all pay and allowances and would subsequently be given a dishonorable discharge.
他向妻子道歉，说，谢谢你支持我，你真是太棒了。我永远无法偿还你对我感到的失望。他没有向西迪基一家或其他被他虐待的新兵道歉，也没有承认他被定罪的任何指控。菲利克斯的律师要求他的客户只在监狱服刑30天，而检方要求判处七年。他被判处10年监禁。他的军衔也将被降低。他将不得不没收所有工资和津贴，并随后被非荣誉退伍。
A total of five Marines ended up being convicted or pleading guilty to charges relating to hazing of recruits of Parris Island. Raheel Siddiqui's death wasn't the first time a recruit died at the depot. In 1956, a drill instructor ordered his platoon to march across a swamp. Six recruits drowned. Two decades later, another recruit was beaten with training sticks and subsequently died. Raheel's death had a ripple effect throughout the United States. Then President Barack Obama had his attention drawn to the case. A Democratic Congresswoman from Detroit reached out to the Siddiquis and petitioned the Marines on their behalf for an unbiased inquiry into hazing.
总共有五名海军陆战队员最终因与帕里斯岛新兵欺凌相关的指控被定罪或认罪。拉希尔·西迪基的死亡并不是该基地第一次有新兵死亡。1956年，一名教官命令他的排穿过一片沼泽。六名新兵溺水身亡。二十年后，另一名新兵被训练棍殴打后死亡。拉希尔的死在美国引起了连锁反应。时任总统巴拉克·奥巴马关注了此案。底特律的一位民主党女国会议员联系了西迪基一家，并代表他们向海军陆战队请愿，要求对欺凌行为进行公正的调查。
In the wake of Raheel's death, Marine Corps Commandant General Robert Kneller, the highest-ranking official in the Marines, stated, We mourn the loss of recruits, Siddiqui, and we will take every step necessary to prevent tragic events like this from happening again. One of Raheel's platoon mates told The New York Times that despite some changes to training, he and the other recruits were still treated badly even after Raheel's death. Let's say you did report something, he said. They changed the DI, and what happens after that? Another DI, who presumably was friends with the prior DI, is going to make your life hell. Several months after Raheel died, a new commanding general was appointed to the Paris Island depot. Austin Renforth said about making changes, including having officers supervise drill instructors more actively and updating a policy letter to emphasize the Marines' zero-tolerance approach to hazing.
在拉希尔去世后，海军陆战队司令罗伯特·内勒将军，即海军陆战队最高级别的官员，表示，我们哀悼新兵西迪基的离世，我们将采取一切必要措施防止此类悲剧再次发生。拉希尔的一名排友告诉《纽约时报》，尽管训练有所改变，但即使在拉希尔死后，他和新兵们仍然受到恶劣对待。他说，假设你确实举报了什么，他们换了教官，那之后会发生什么？另一位大概是前教官朋友的教官会让你的生活变成地狱。拉希尔去世几个月后，一位新的指挥官被任命为帕里斯岛基地。奥斯汀·伦福斯谈到做出改变，包括让军官更积极地监督教官，并更新政策信以强调海军陆战队对欺凌行为的零容忍态度。
In an interview with The New York Times, he admitted that he'd thought about contacting Raheel's parents but decided, quote, I just didn't feel it was my place. The Siddiqui struggled with the silence they received from the Marines after Raheel died. His sister, Sidra, told the Detroit Free Press newspaper that she now had difficulty saying the Pledge of Allegiance, a patriotic verse that students at most American public schools have to recite. Her faith in the country her parents had immigrated to for a better life had been broken. The Siddiquis chose not to speak to most reporters as they were disappointed with the way their son had been portrayed in the media, as though he were weak or unprepared for boot camp. In order to be accepted as a recruit, he'd had to pass a psychological exam. None of them had ever witnessed any signs pointing to Raheel having a mental illness or suicidal thoughts.
在接受《纽约时报》采访时，他承认他曾想过联系拉希尔的父母，但决定，引用他的话，我只是觉得那不是我的位置。西迪基一家在拉希尔死后从海军陆战队那里感受到的沉默中挣扎。他的妹妹西德拉告诉《底特律自由报》，她现在很难说出效忠誓词，这是大多数美国公立学校学生必须背诵的爱国诗句。她对父母为了更好的生活而移民的国家所持有的信念已经破灭。西迪基一家选择不与大多数记者交谈，因为他们对儿子在媒体上的形象感到失望，仿佛他很软弱或没有为新兵训练营做好准备。为了被接受为新兵，他必须通过心理测试。他们中没有人见过任何迹象表明拉希尔有精神疾病或自杀念头。
They remain convinced that Raheel would never take his own life and believe there are unanswered questions relating to his death. The family lodged a civil suit suing the federal government for $100 million for their son's death. Their lawyer was arguing that the Marines had been negligent when recruiting Raheel in failing to tell him there had been allegations of abuse against Muslim recruits at Paris Island. At a time when the Marine Corps was eager to attract recruits from more diverse backgrounds, it seemed they had a duty of care to ensure those recruits would be safe from possible hate crimes. The Siddiquis also wanted Raheel's death certificate amended. A coroner had marked his cause of death as suicide, but his family thought it should be listed as undetermined. Because of the way Raheel's fate tripped over the stairwell causing him to fall awkwardly, it wasn't clear whether he had truly intended to take his own life. Perhaps he'd just been trying to escape Joseph Felix.
他们仍然坚信拉希尔永远不会自杀，并认为关于他的死亡还有未解之谜。家人提起民事诉讼，就儿子的死亡向联邦政府索赔1亿美元。他们的律师辩称，海军陆战队在招募拉希尔时存在疏忽，没有告诉他帕里斯岛曾有针对穆斯林新兵的虐待指控。在海军陆战队渴望吸引更多不同背景的新兵时，他们似乎有责任确保这些新兵免受可能的仇恨犯罪伤害。西迪基一家还希望修改拉希尔的死亡证明。验尸官将他的死因标记为自杀，但他的家人认为应该列为未定。由于拉希尔在楼梯间绊倒导致他笨拙地坠落，不清楚他是否真的打算自杀。也许他只是想逃离约瑟夫·菲利克斯。
The lawsuit was ultimately dismissed due to a federal precedent that prevents the US government from being sued for harm to military personnel. The judge who made the ruling said he had no other option and expressed strong reservations about having to do so. The Siddiquis have retained Raheel's bedroom as a kind of shrine to him. It has been kept perfectly clean and is dotted with awards that Raheel won for his academic achievements. And hanging in the closet is a reminder of what he wanted to achieve. The perfectly pressed dress uniform that Raheel would have worn upon graduating from training with the Marines. The Siddiquis There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
该诉讼最终因一项防止美国政府因军事人员受伤害而被起诉的联邦先例而被驳回。做出裁决的法官表示他别无选择，并对不得不这样做表示强烈保留。西迪基一家保留了拉希尔的卧室，作为对他的一种纪念。它保持得非常干净，点缀着拉希尔因学术成就而获得的奖项。衣柜里挂着他想要实现的目标的提醒。拉希尔在海军陆战队训练毕业时本应穿上的熨烫得完美的礼服制服。西迪基一家。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。